being a twin you're always identified as
a unit we've experienced every moment in
life together you learned to drive
together you go to school together in
the same class and went through the same
hardships as teenagers we work together
we're on the phone together a lot you
feel a connection that you just don't
with anybody else we've been together
since day one it's been important for us
as individuals to forge our own paths
living for our part is tough but I
always know she has my back 100%
I live in index Washington at the base
of the Cascade Mountains every day I
knew sounds cliche but I just wake up
feeling totally blessed it's beautiful
usually in the morning I drink my coffee
I walk my dog and a little bit before a
night and I call Keyshia or she calls me
I'm a paralegal I'm kind of the
assistant for the attorney all in all
it's amazing having my sister as a boss
we're very close and obviously very
candid with each other but you know
we're a team working together in a sense
but different places I'm an immigration
attorney in New York it's obviously a
fast-paced life but I do really love New
Yorkers
I love the vibrant diversity that the
city has that's truly unique in the
world of all the places I've ever been
starting my own practice it's long hours
it's high stress so I really appreciate
the work that Jazmin does I definitely
encourage her every day you know on the
bad days I'm like let's get off and like
take a ride jazz and I have never really
been competitive but on the bike it's a
different story we're very competitive
on the bike Keyshia is faster on the
bike hands down I would win in a race I
would say Keysha is more competitive
than me I'm a nice sister I would say
I'm better at snowboarding I think she
would agree with that I've run marathons
and so running was always my physical
outlet but the bike has really been a
game changer for one you never really
know when you're gonna have that space
in your day and so if I have a break
maybe in meetings I can take that
opportunity and really seize it
I'll see you a class that we want to do
and I'll say hey are you down to do
Alex's 5:30
fYI a 30-year time I live in a super
small town about 600 people it's pretty
cool to hop on the peloton bike and all
of a sudden I'm right
with thousands of people from around the
world I will filter the leaderboard to
just her and I I'm initially hot out of
the get-go Jasmine can be leading almost
the entire ride except for the end I
usually have more steam than she does
Jasmine has never made a better time
than me having this physical outlet is
really cool it's been another tool for
us to stay connected and to see one or
another despite the distance jazz and I
have matching tattoos they're identical
it makes me think of her every time I
see it and I like to keep it as a
reminder of where I'm from it just
reminds us of home which is here and I
guess just being together
[Music]
you